et notre invité ce matin c'est François
brille bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes le président
de la CFE-CGC c'est le syndicat des
cadres et on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
bonjour Christelle Bertrand bonjour Yann
bonjour François-Marie bonjour La
Dépêche Christelle et on va évidemment
parler de cette journée de mobilisation
hier à l'appel des syndicats dont vous
évidemment François brille mobilisation
qui a été plus importante que la semaine
dernière en tout cas dans la rue après
on va revenir dans le détail sur le
reste comment vous la jugez vous cette
journée de mobilisation
le fait que plus de gens qui soient
mobilisés c'est important je pense et de
toute façon même le niveau est important
et c'est aussi beaucoup le niveau de
motivation des gens je crois cette
mobilisation finalement c'est une image
assez assez bonne de ce qu'est le niveau
de rejet dans la population plus de 80%
aujourd'hui plus de 90% pour les
salariés les gens qui travaillent voilà
on a on a l'expression un mouvement
social c'est toujours l'expression d'une
majorité de la population et c'est très
très bien que ça a été très visible
alors les cadres sont pas toujours très
présents dans les moments de sociaux là
comment vous analysez la présence des
cadres dans ce mouvement là ils sont
nombreux alors je veux dire deux choses
d'abord parce que c'est vrai que nous à
la CFE-CGC on nous présente souvent
comme le syndicat des cadres moi je le
dé pas parce que c'est un peu la vérité
mais la vérité c'est aussi que c'est le
syndicat de l'encadrement c'est-à-dire
des techniciens des agents de maîtrise
des cadres et de tous les agents de la
fonction publique et pourquoi ils sont
nombreux bah parce que en fait il y a
deux choses il y a il y a une espèce de
ras-le-bol quand même de la part des
gens que je représente de considérer
finalement que leur travail est de plus
en plus dur et qui ne va qui va de moins
en moins finalement dans le sens de
l'entreprise et de son développement
c'est un peu ça aussi la financarisation
je vais pas faire un topo là-dessus ce
matin je pense pas que ce soit le sujet
mais si vous voulez ce phénomène de
société finalement qui tente à diriger
l'activité la concentration les
responsabilités que tout le monde vers
la maximisation du profit pour
l'actionnaire ça finit par fatiguer un
peu tout le monde ils sont dans la rue
contre la réforme des retraites mais
aussi parce qu'ils cherchent un sens à
leur travail et donc le fait qu'on
vienne leur dire l'état a besoin
d'argent parce que c'est ça le premier
motif de la réforme on a besoin d'argent
parce qu'il y a plus de ligne
budgétaires pour financer qui l'hôpital
l'École etc et donc on va le prendre sur
les retraites en fait c'est un
supportable pour des gens qui constatent
tous les jours que finalement leur
travail est toujours un peu plus
difficile un peu moins bien rémunéré et
que par ailleurs les entreprises sont
inondées d'argent public sans
discrimination sans distinction et
surtout sans conditions
oui il y a une grande fatigue bien sûr
c'est granulaire tout le monde est
possède la moyenne ces personnes donc il
y a des gens qui vont vous dire vous
allez vous allez en trouver nous aussi
d'ailleurs qui vont dire non je suis
super motivé c'est super et c'est bien
d'ailleurs qu'il en reste encore
aujourd'hui une grande partie qui sont
très motivés et il y en a d'autres qui
finalement sont un peu désillusionnés de
ce qui a été leur investissement dans en
arrière dans leurs études qui arrivent
en fin de carrière et qui aujourd'hui
voit que finalement la chose qui
préoccupe le gouvernement ben c'est de
les faire travailler un peu plus sachant
que je voudrais répondre à une question
que vous alliez peut-être me poser
est-ce que les cadres sont touchés bien
certain ne le sont pas par la réforme
d'autres beaucoup le sont beaucoup parce
que vous savez un cadre de 50 ans dans
le secteur bancaire c'est souvent
quelqu'un qui est rentré comme employé
et qui a fait de la formation qui a fait
l'école des techniciens de bancaires
c'est souvent un agent de maîtrise dans
l'industrie c'est quelqu'un qui rentrait
comme ouvrier qui s'est investi qui a
fait de la formation
ça ça va pas jusque là écoutez moi je
pense je pense aujourd'hui oui qui a une
grande fatigue qui est liée à une forme
de ras-le-bol de la façon dont la
société est gérée en termes de priorité
alors hier l'année ce qu'on a pu faire
des défilés c'est qu'il y avait une
forte représentation du secteur privé en
revanche dans le secteur public à
molimilisation semble un peu moins de
que la semaine dernière est-ce que c'est
quelque chose d'inquiétant est-ce que
c'est un mauvais signal pour la suite
non non non moi je crois pas du tout
vous savez le le ça vous inquiète pas le
fait qu'il y ait moins de grévise ça
vous inquiète pas
c'est les gens qui se mobilisent dans la
rue faire la grève c'est pas facile
c'est perdre de l'argent les gens de la
fonction publique ils ont perdu en 20
ans plus de 30 % de pouvoir d'achat
c'est une catastrophe c'est une
responsabilité écrasante pour nous
dirigeants depuis 20 ans c'est le gel du
point d'indice et donc aujourd'hui faire
deux jours de grève dans un mois pour
quelqu'un qui est professeur d'anglais
dans une banlieue de Paris ou qui est
agent administrative dans une mairie
c'est perdre beaucoup d'argent et
peut-être un peu handicapé les vacances
qui vont venir analyse quand tu fais le
gouvernement aujourd'hui c'est dire peu
importe le nombre de personnes qui a
dans la rue l'important c'est le taux de
grévistes parce que c'est eux qui
bloquent le pays donc s'il est en baisse
c'est plutôt un bon signe est-ce que
c'est pas un mauvais signal envoyé au
gouvernement cette baisse du taux de pas
du tout vous savez ce que dit le
gouvernement sur le sujet j'ai appris à
le prendre avec beaucoup de distance
bien sûr il y aurait eu 10 millions de
personnes dans la rue
illustrer aller chercher le taux de
grève dans la dans une sous-préfecture
en disant ça a baissé à cet endroit là
c'est ça l'indicateur qui est important
pour nous
développes le gouvernement a perdu la
bataille de l'opinion et ça les rend un
peu nerveux et quand on est un peu
nerveux quand on commence à perdre le
match et ben on finit par faire et par
dire des bêtises donc vous savez sur
l'argumentaire qui justifie sa réforme
le gouvernement dit n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui quand même il faut le
relever quand j'entends Olivier du
Olivier du socle ministre du Travail
passé à l'Assemblée en disant le système
est infaillite franchement il se fout du
monde quoi comment est-ce qu'on peut
dire qu'un système qui a aujourd'hui 180
milliards de réserves étant faillite
franchement c'est pas sérieux il se
déguste lui-même on va venir sur le fond
mais pour rester sur la mobilisation un
mot
vous parliez des sous-préfectures
justement la France des sous-préfectures
comme on dit à fortement mobiliser hier
comment vous analysez cette chose qui
est un peu nouvelle d'habitude c'est
plutôt les métropoles mathématiquement
écoutez ces deux choses d'abord c'est
l'organisation du mouvement qui je crois
a fait beaucoup de place aussi aux
mobilisations régionales et c'est la
volonté répartie de façon très uniforme
dans le pays
de se mobiliser vous savez moi j'habite
en Savoie à côté d'Albertville les
chiffres qui ont été enregistrés à la
manifestation d'Albertville sont plus
forts que jamais et notamment hier il y
a une mobilisation encore plus forte et
c'était très très visible que le 19
janvier et ça c'est l'expression d'une
volonté partagée tout secteur confondu
toute génération confondues dans les
préfectures c'est plus facile en famille
par exemple
si vous voulez dans cette dimension plus
accessible c'est plus facile d'accéder
au défilé il y a tout un tas de détails
pratiques qui font que et bien les gens
ils ont ils ont cette volonté en même
temps peut-être presque cette fierté de
participer à ce mouvement là pour
manifester leur rejet de cette réforme
du mouvement de nouvelles journées ont
été annoncées la semaine prochaine mardi
et samedi prochain et Gabriel Attal
était l'invité hier soir du 20h de TF1
il vous a fait passer un message on
écoute
mon message il est clair au syndicat si
vous continuez à vous mobiliser
continuer à le faire en respectant les
Français qui travaillent qui se lèvent
le matin parce que à la fin quand il y a
des blocages c'est toujours eux qui
trinquent les Français qui vont
travailler ou qui prennent un peu de
vacances bien mérité donc c'est ça
évidemment la demande vous entendez ce
message
seraient des gens qui ne travaillent pas
enfin ils se rend pas compte moi j'y
étais dans le défilé hier on était
plusieurs centaines plusieurs milliers
de la CFE-CGC ce sont mes collègues ce
sont tous des gens qui travaillent et
qui représentent des gens qui
travaillent
le coup du blocage franchement c'est pas
sérieux en plus il y a les enquêtes
d'opinion s'il y a plus que ça comme
argument au gouvernement franchement
c'est faible c'est très très faible moi
ça me surprend pas sur la suite à donner
à ce mouvement jusqu'où il faut aller
pour vous
l'avez fait hier ou est-ce qu'il faut
aller plus loin avec des blocages avec
des grèves reconductibles ça je sais pas
je veux pas le pronostiquer comme vous
savez les les décisions elles sont
prises en inter syndicale moi mon
souhait c'est que le
décalage à 184 ans soit retirée je pense
que aujourd'hui le gouvernement n'a plus
d'autres choix il n'a plus d'autre choix
Gabriel Attal le même une intervient
beaucoup hein c'est bien normal
peut-être d'ailleurs qu'à la fin il sera
le seul parce qu'on voit bien qu'il y a
moins en moins de personnes de la
majorité présidentielle qui veulent
intervenir sur ce sujet aussi bancal
mais il intervenait en disant ouais ce
que veulent les Français ce que souhaite
les Français et la callire les sondages
il a qu'à regarder ce qui se passe ce
que veulent les Français c'est le
retrait de la mesure donc s'il veut
vraiment respecter la volonté le désir
des Français et bien il retire leur
mesure elle n'est pas justifiée sur le
plan même technique
dans l’inter syndicale c'est-à-dire que
vous êtes tous d'accord pour dire que
tous les moyens sont bons pour obtenir
le retrait de cette mesure vous savez
jamais tous les moyens sont bons voilà
jamais tous les moyens sont bons un
mouvement social c'est un mouvement qui
est organisé qui est cohérent et qui
mobilise des moyens sous la limite c'est
tout ce qui à moindre ira la qualité et
la force de ce mouvement là voilà c'est
ça la limite elle est tactique mais en
même temps
c'est supprimer des trains pour les
Français qui veulent partir moi je pense
effectivement à la popularité des c'est
un équilibre vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est à dire que la solidarité de
l'ensemble des Français elle est très
très forte aujourd'hui donc il faudra
être extrêmement attentif à
ne pas développer des actions qui
pourraient à moins de rire ce niveau de
solidarité
sur les coupures de courant vous étiez
plutôt opposé à ce type d'action est-ce
que vous voulez toujours
vos collègues syndicalistes disent la
désobéissance civile c'est aussi un mode
d'action pour être audible quand
effectivement que des actions comme ça à
ciblées qui apparaissent un peu
agressive dans l'agressivité et dirigée
vers d'autres personnes que ceux qui
sont responsables pour le coup de de ce
projet je pense que c'est
contre-productif voilà c'est pour ça que
je souhaite pas exemple après vous savez
le le
terme même de blocage
il est pas toujours bien caractérisé si
vous voulez suivant le contexte
pour vous c'est la limite les Français
ne fassent plus la popularité et
l'adhésion du mouvement s'il y a
aujourd'hui des
comment dire je reprends le terme de
blocage d'arrêt de production s'il y a
des arrêts de production qui viennent à
rendre le mouvement un peu populaire
alors à ce moment effectivement ça
n'aura pas été une bonne chose de le
faire et là-dessus tout le monde est
d'accord où il y a des divisions avec la
CGT et qui elle est en fait je vais vous
dire sur cette question là ce sera
difficile de nous diviser aujourd'hui le
camp qui est divisé c'est le camp de la
majorité présidentielle les députés et
même les ministres puisque Franck
Riester a fait une déclaration il a dit
la vérité en fait quand il a dit que les
femmes étaient plus touchés que les
hommes bon il s'est fait redresser les
oreilles en pointe mais voilà
visiblement même le gouvernement est
divisé sur le section là vous misez vous
sur une division la majorité
présidentielle c'est normal bien sûr moi
je suis mise sur une division de la
majorité plaisantielle je constate
qu'elle est en train de s'installer et
je trouve ça parfait le gouvernement de
son côté mise sur une division du
mouvement social il constate que l'Inter
syndicale est solide et je trouve ça
parfait en une mise sur une division du
mouvement social une mise aussi sur
l'épuisement des grévistes à un moment
où les prix augmentent ils misent sur le
fait que les gens puissent pas se passer
de plusieurs journées de salaire
combien de mobilisation comme ça
faudra-t-il pour faire retirer le texte
et est-ce que les gens peuvent assumer
votre question elle est très pertinente
effectivement moi j'aurais souhaité que
dès ce soir le président de la
République intervienne et qui fasse un
discours vous savez il fait des très
beaux discours le président de la
République moi je les adore c'est
discours j'ai compris bah je lui demande
qui nous fasse un beau discours comment
en avril comme en avril 2021 et qui
disent j'ai compris j'ai changé
le pays j'aime mon pays et je ne veux
pas le brusquer je retire mon projet
voilà c'est ça que tout le monde attend
c'est ça qui devait qu'il devrait faire
s'il veut passer à la postérité comme
étant un président qui rassemble son
pays et non qui le divise moi ce qui
vous faudra comme ça tenir jusqu'à la
mi-mai jusqu'à jusqu'au vote du texte et
comment on fait pour tenir aussi
longtemps mais c'est une bonne question
on est en train de réfléchir et de
s'organiser pour ce que si vraiment
c'est nécessaire le mouvement puisse
tenir dans la durée mais ça vous savez
on l'a déclaré dès le premier jour
d'autres communication du 10 janvier on
a dit on inscrit le mouvement dans la
durée donc
ça veut dire trouver les moyens de payer
les grévistes vous savez les moyens elle
a encore appartiennent aux organisations
c'est comme souvent je le rappelle on le
commente assez peu mais une organisation
syndicale sur organisation démocratique
des structures internes c'est la section
syndicale qui décide dans son
environnement des moyens à mettre en
place et à mobiliser les salariés par
exemple nous on fera tout ce qui est
possible pour atteindre notre objectif
et faire que ce mouvement social finisse
par triompher et fasse reculer le
gouvernement sur le fond vous nous en
avez un peu parlé tout à l'heure mais
vous êtes un syndicat réformé vous
n'êtes pas sensible à ce discours du
gouvernement qui dit que cette réforme
des retraites ça vise à sauver le régime
par répartition et Gabriel Attal
redisait hier un discours qu'on a
entendu qui est que cette réforme elle
est faite pour les Français elle est
plus modestes parce que leur patrimoine
c'est leur pension de retraite
non je n'entends pas du tout moi je suis
un syndicat attaché effectivement à une
réforme juste et intelligente je
représente des gens qui ont des
responsabilités fortes dans leurs
entreprises et qui n'ont pas peur
d'affronter les systèmes complexes de
regarder les tableaux de chiffres de les
mettre en correspondance de faire des
corrélations moi je prétends que j'ai
plus de compétences à travers mon
syndicat que dans tous les cabinets des
ministères réunis en face de moi ils me
font pas peur en fait et sur la question
des retraites le système on l'a analysé
on l'a regardé on est gestionnaire des
systèmes complémentaires tous les mois
en comité directeur on est on examine
ces sujets là toutes les semaines en
bureau national on les examine depuis
des dizaines d'années on prend des
responsabilités dans les systèmes
absolument pas absolument pas
aujourd'hui il y a 180 milliards de
réserves dans les régimes
complémentaires il y a presque 30
milliards il y a 27,3 milliards dans
l'enfant de réserve des retraites qui a
été mis en place pour compléter le
fonctionnement de la CNAV il y a une
dette sociale qui est de 243 milliards
que j'ai dans la dans la comment dire
dans la Cadès la part des retraites est
très faible dans la dette sociale il y a
plus de 200 milliards de la dette
sociale c'est la maladie et quand
d'actifs
il dit aussi parle de l'allongement de
l'espérance de vie Olivier du soft n'a
pas tapé sur son portable espérance de
vie il n'a pas eu l'occurrence de
l'Insee qui vient lui dire que depuis
2014 l'espérance de vie n'augmente pas
Olivier du socle dit n'importe quoi donc
moi si vous voulez je peux rentrer dans
l'argumentaire je l'ai fait avec lui
mais c'est argument ne fonctionne pas
l'argument le sol le vrai celui qui a
été mobilisé avant les élections
législatives il est de dire je n'ai plus
assez d'argent au niveau de l'État pour
pouvoir financer les grands projets que
politiquement je souhaite porter et ça
c'est vrai ça c'est vrai et donc cet
argent pourquoi là pourquoi l'État n'a
plus d'argent on était il y a une
dizaine d'années à 90 milliards d'aide
aux entreprises aujourd'hui on a plus de
200 milliards mais c'est quoi cette
gabegie d'argent public qui tourne comme
ça comme un comme une lance de pompiers
sur le sable pour alimenter les
entreprises qui le transforment
immédiatement les économies auraient dû
être fait ailleurs c'est ça mais
attendez quand on met plus de 200 sur
les entreprises qui le transforment
immédiatement en dividendes et on rachat
d'action 47 milliards de rachat
d'actions sur les deux dernières années
mais comment on peut supporter ça le
rachat d'action vous savez c'est un tas
de billets qu'on met dans cette pièce
qui serait trop de petites pour les
contenir on l'asperge descends et on y
met le feu et on vient nous dire on n'a
pas de capacité à intervenir parce que
aujourd'hui l'État n'a plus d'argent et
on a cessé de le dépenser dans des
actions non conditionnées parce que le
gouvernement dit on est encore ouvert à
la discussion on peut encore discuter de
certains points est-ce que vous vous
avez envie de retourner autour de la
table avec Olivier du saute
moi j'y vais c'est pas un problème mais
il faut retirer la mesure à 64 ans voilà
vous savez que c'est non négociable pour
reprendre les mots négociable ah bah
voilà c'est ça
les arguments enfin les arguments on
peut pas les entendre ces arguments là
les arguments sont pas bon vous savez
moi je les dis souvent à la première
ministre je suis d'une organisation
syndicale qui a pris ses responsabilités
sur la question des retraites ça pas
toujours été facile à assumer sur le
terrain quand on a eu signé certains
accords qu'on s'est avancer pour
soutenir tel ou tel type de réforme
parfois les gens qu'on représente ils
nous disent dis donc quand même etc on
leur dit mais oui mais justement on est
obligé à intervenir parce que sinon on
va mettre en danger le système or en
l'occurrence là ça n'est pas le cas mais
pour vous les 64 ans c'est non
négociable aussi dire que même s'il y a
une élégation par exemple au niveau de
l'index Seigneur qui serait rendu
coercitif comme le propose aujourd'hui
le gouvernement même s'il y a une
amélioration sur la retraite des femmes
par exemple 64 ans
c'est la ligne rouge 64 ans c'est le
moyen pour le gouvernement de rentrer
cache tout de suite de l'argent et senti
une monsieur est une mesure injuste
parce qu'elle cible des populations
particulières et y compris des femmes
donc si le gouvernement vient vers nous
en disant mais j'ai analysé les
populations cibles celle qui payent plus
que les hommes et je vais mettre en
place des dispositifs qui vont à moindre
rire cet impact là mais qui va payer
alors
qui va payer les 13 milliards
d'économies que le gouvernement compte
faire qui va payer moi je pose la
question si toutes les catégories qui
aujourd'hui sont plus visées que les
autres mais finalement on va à moindre
rire la charge mais au final qui va
payer et donc pourquoi faire cette
réforme cette réforme n'a aucun sens en
fait la vérité c'est ça cette réforme
n'a pas de sens on peut pas avoir en
même temps le discours sur le partage de
la valeur en disant il faut que le
travail soit mieux payé et faire ce
qu'il faut en termes de politique de loi
qui fera que le travail soit sera moins
payé alors aujourd'hui un combat dans la
rue il y a aussi un combat à l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que vous attendez
quelque chose du débat parlementaire
est-ce qu'il peut en retirer est-ce que
vous pouvez obtenir moi je sens beaucoup
des débats j'attends beaucoup des débats
vous savez c'est le débat qui nous a
porté finalement je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure on a gagné la bataille de
l'opinion grâce au débat qu'on a
instauré sur le sujet on a fait de la
pédagogie voilà le gouvernement toujours
veut manipuler l'argument d'autorité en
disant on fait de la pédagogie parce que
moi j'ai raison a priori et bah non
c'est faux en fait pour l'instant qu'on
rentre dans le débat si vous voulez
le Parlement et on fera ce qu'il faut
pour faire douter la majorité
présidentielle et c'est déjà le cas et
bien on les informe quand il nous pose
des questions on répond aux questions on
fait notre travail eux font leur travail
ils ont une responsabilité un mandat au
nom de ceux qui les ont élus je le
respecte énormément nous on fait le
nôtre et donc on les informe on donne
leur point de vue on leur demande d'en
tenir compte voilà on sait que question
sur le débat parlementaire on sait que
l'issue où c'est l'article 47 1 et la
loi peut être appliquée pardonnant bah
ordonnance ou le 49-3 et elle est
appliquée aussi est-ce que il y a
quelque chose à attendre du débat
parlementaire il y a tout attendre du
débat parlementaire dans une démocratie
moi je souhaite que la démocratie
fonctionne on a une démocratie politique
on a une démocratie sociale je souhaite
que la démocratie comme fonctionne j'y
crois encore j'y crois encore je pense
que la raison l'intelligence c'est la
responsabilité peuvent revenir à ce
gouvernement et à notre président merci
François brille merci beaucoup d'avoir
notre invité ce matin la Une de La
Dépêche est évidemment cette
mobilisation Toulouse encore plus de
mobilisation à la Une de votre journal
80 000 personnes merci d'avoir été avec
nous merci François Omri